tonight the disgraceful radical extreme
democratic socialist party they had what
will likely be the first of many failed
votes to attempt to impeach a duly
elected president will somebody please
give these people a copy of the
Constitution a lot more coming up also
we begin tonight with members of the
quote squad ramping up their attacks on
anyone and everyone who dares to
disagree with their extreme radical
socialist ideas now 2020 hopefuls they
have been put on notice everyone in the
Democratic Party you better fall in line
or a you might be called a racist or be
they are keeping the squad the
equivalent of an enemies list of fellow
Democrats that oppose them I guess so
they can campaign against them it's
getting that ugly now the squad has
already lobbed racism charges against
both President Trump and even their own
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and while Pelosi is
totally powerless as we've been telling
you to defend herself the president is
firing back in a big way just moments
ago the president wrapped up what was a
massive rally in Greenville in North
Carolina where he had a very special
message for the new radical leaders of
this democratic extreme socialist party
take a look so representative Omar
blamed the United States
for the terrorist attacks on our country
saying that terrorism is a reaction to
our involvement in other people's
affairs her colleague representative
Rasheeda
Talib
agreed with Omar's characterization of
9/11 and said that members of Congress
who support Israel forgot what country
they represent Cortez said that illegal
immigrants are more American than any
person who seeks to keep them out ever
will be can you believe that that's what
she's saying
[Music]
she described contemporary America
that's you that's me that's all of us as
garbage garbage and they're so angry
even yesterday they won on the stage I
said let me watch this and the anger
they were trying to be nice but it's
hard it's hard for them to do that
you know smelly Walmart voter is
irredeemable deplorable x' people that
cling to their god their guns their
bibles and religion few politicians have
had the courage to call out the radical
base of the Democratic Party but that's
why you we the American people elected
Donald Trump in spite of what New York
California Washington and other liberal
states wanted and while the media mob
the Democrats attacked this president
they do it compulsively obsessively all
those approval ratings among Republicans
keeps going way up and today new polls
show the president's numbers actually
increased by five points according to
another poll forty nine percent of
likely voters certainly a plurality
believe the accusations of racism
against President Trump are nothing more
than a political ploy that is up six
percentage points over the last poll
conducted and here's why let me help
educate the radical masses while you may
not like it the term love it love
America leave America it is nothing to
do with race and by the way is hardly a
new characterization or concept to the
loudest critics of the what we call
blame America first crowd was it racist
for senator Kamala Harris to tell
President Trump today that he needs to
quote go back from where he came from
she did that today and get this in 2016
scores of celebrities other media elites
remember they all vowed to leave the
United States a president Trump was
elected oh yeah there are their names
well there's nothing racist about that
they didn't like him the only problem
none of them actually left we even
offered a plane with caviar and
champagne but they had to promise never
to come back and tonight when the media
mob and the Democrats focus their daily
attacks on the president every second
minute hour of every 24-hour day it's
just one pathetic last-ditch effort to
take the president down they still have
not accepted the 2016
election results of We the People the
nine-month FBI investigation will use
the words of Lisa Paige nothing they
found nothing
Peter struck no there there is a relates
to collusion conspiracy to conspire with
Russia the bipartisan Senate
investigation same result nothing the
house investigation
nothing Muller concluded no conspiracy
at all with Russia no collusion and of
course no obstruction as per the
Attorney General Deputy Attorney General
and office of legal counsel so their
phantom charges of obstruction and
collusion all fell short and the great
likelihood is that one week from tonight
I'm looking forward to this
when Muller testifies before Congress
and I would even argue at this moment if
he's silly enough to testify before
Congress because they'll have to answer
real questions from real Republicans I
would say the yards are very high that
it will be another boomerang against the
Democrats even if Devin Nunez is right
there likely coordinating what they're
going to say and how he's gonna respond
why do I suspect they would do something
like that now what the Democrats have
left in their playbook all right Russia
Russia Russia
that's a dud obstruction obstruction a
dud okay we'll try racism racism that
will be a dud too let's use the playbook
the Democrats use in every single
election season although it's not every
two and four years anymore
as I've always laid out on this program
and showed you ad after ad FT and in the
history of no it's like everyday now you
have hysteria boiling over the
Democratic congressman Al Green he
actually launched what was the first of
probably many pathetic attempts to
impeach the president
resound Li defeated in the House of
Representatives this is a national
embarrassment
will somebody please get these radical
Democrats a constitution and tell them
to read it if not maybe we can have
somebody read it for them whatever they
want because they don't clearly
understand it take a look I just heard
that the
United States House of Representatives
has overwhelmingly voted to kill the
most ridiculous project I've ever been
involved in the resolution how stupid is
that own impeachment I want to thank
those Democrats because many of them
voted for us the vote was a totally
lopsided 332 to 95 to 1
now of course congressman green is just
doing the bidding of the new leaders of
the Democratic Party remember this from
newly elected congresswoman remember to
leave remember she said this so nice
safe welcoming and warm and inclusive
take a look when your son looks at you
says mama look you won bullies don't win
baby they don't because we're gonna go
in there win it and during an interview
today on CBS today to leap offered no
apology or attraction for her vile
comments about the President of the
United States why would you ever
apologize for doing that take a look day
one I truly believe that he has
committed and P chable offenses and me
you know but even if you believe I
didn't do it on the House floor and I'm
gonna be on apologetic in myself 70% of
Americans curse I am real this is who I
am I'm rooted in where I come from and
it's very common for me and for many of
my residents to say things like that but
so you don't regret I mean ottoman
apologetic about it
all right this radical Democratic Party
is in a very dark very scary place there
are no more moderates in today's extreme
Democratic Party as socialism is
completely in radicalism completely
taken over even far left liberal Nancy
Pelosi the San Francisco liberal treat
is now considered to moderate the
so-called Squad is controlling all
aspects of the Democratic Party's
message in their platform anyone who
gets in their way or doesn't fully
support their radical dreams is accused
of either bigotry or whatever and today
congresswoman to leave became the second
member of the squad to actually accuse
her own House Speaker Nancy Pelosi of
racism this is number two
two of the four radicals that are
leading in the house and influencing the
2020 Democratic candidates let's take a
look are you speaking to Nancy Pelosi
our teams are in communication our
Chiefs are but shouldn't it be a face to
face I'm very protective with all due
respect
she doesn't need protection I want to
know if you were she's a new member not
the speaker no every right to sit down
with her in any moment any time with any
of us she is Speaker of the House she
can ask for a meeting to sit down with
us for clarification the fact of the
knowledge is and I've done racial
justice work in our country for a long
time acknowledge the fact that we are
women of color so when you do singles
out be aware of that and what you're
doing pretty serious accusation against
the so-called speaker really the speaker
in name only Nance Nancy Pelosi and as
they keep reminding you she's now merely
a bystander in this new radical
socialist extreme Democratic Party which
is why she can't even defend herself
from their attacks remember she asked
last week you have anything to say say
it to my face
Oh what did it AOC do she goes right to
Twitter and runs out publicly and
attacks her again
take a look are you concerned that the
president is goatee you know what with
all due respect let's not waste our time
on that we're talking about what we're
going to do to help the American people
our caucus is unified on all of that
throughout the whole campaign I said to
the men candidates don't even mention
his name everybody knows who he is you
don't have to describe him to anybody
we're not having him set our agenda
we're setting our own agenda she's not
setting the agenda at all right Ocasio
cortes Talib Omar and Presley are
running the show the 2020 presidential
hopefuls they're all sucking up to this
new leadership their beliefs are beyond
scary it would destroy America as we
know it we know about their dreams to
turn America into a socialist eco state
known as the green new deal but perhaps
even more alarming or their views by
some in this group of four on
Israel and the Jewish people
congresswoman to lead who you just saw
actually wrote for louis farrakhan's
racist anti-semitic newspaper
she also piles around with a known bigot
her name Linda Sarsour facts are sore
was invited guests at the leap
swearing-in so sore openly supports
Sharia law blamed her bad reputation on
the quote Jewish media and as you can
see
congresswoman Omar also hangs out with
Linda Sarsour no surprise there
Omar is frequently tweeted anti-semitic
tropes she once accused lawmakers of
being controlled by quote Jewish money
remember the phrase it's all about the
Benjamins
Omar even accused evil Israel of
hypnotizing the world but in today's
interview with Gayle King well
congresswoman Omar says he has no
regrets she regrets nothing actually
burst out laughing when I asked about
anti-semitism let's take a look
oftentimes there are things that you
might say might not hold weight for you
but to someone else right the way that
we hear and consume information is very
different than how the next person might
so you don't regret your words either
I do not would you like people to get
that area then you were not anti-semitic
Oh certainly not
yes would you like to make that clear
yes I mean and that nothing I said and
this to me was meant for that purpose
well least to me okay well yes no
anti-semitism it's no laughing matter
neither is Al Qaeda or the way Americans
talk about those that killed 3,000 of
our fellow Americans on 9/11 or the
terrorist group Hezbollah yet
congresswoman Omar finds apparently all
that to be somewhat humorous and funny
as we have previously played on this
program now her behavior obvious beliefs
are pretty vile pretty sickening Omar
now plans to introduce a resolution
declaring her support for the
anti-semitic BDS movement which is a
boycott all things Israel and Omar and
other members of her squad are now the
perfect representation of today's
two-phase democratic party built on
even pony and feigned moral outrage each
week they call Trump other Republicans
racist sexist you know the routine
yet no outrage over Omar's veralyn
anti-semitism no concern over to leaves
work in Farah Khan's paper meanwhile
Democratic Ralph
NorAm Democrat Ralph Norum you know the
governor of the Commonwealth of Virginia
apparently sleeping peacefully in the
governor's mansion after his fellow
Democrats didn't really seem to care
that he dressed up either in blackface
or in a Ku Klux Klan outfit wonder if
Donald Trump did that how they'd react
twenty twenty Democrats are busy kissing
the ring of the Reverend Al Sharpton who
became well known for anti-semitic
bigoted language we played a lot of it
last night Hillary Clinton's mentor she
said her mentor Robert Byrd well he used
to be in the Ku Klux Klan Al Gore's
father tried to block the 1964 Civil
Rights Act at historic legislation
Lyndon Johnson relied on Republican
support to get it passed and went
forward as the Democrats went forward
with a filibuster the list goes on we
don't even have time to list all of
creepy crazy sleepy Uncle Joe's racist
remarks and policies over the years and
let's talk about charges of sexual
misconduct again selectively feigned
moral outrage only when it said that
only when it's a Republican or Donald
Trump or Donald Trump supporter or John
Donald Trump appointee remember the I
believers and the Cavanaugh hearings
well they're nowhere to be found when a
Democrat is accused of wrongdoing case
in point the lieutenant governor of
Virginia who Gayle King interviewed two
women one accused him of rape another
said violence sexual assault both
telling people at the time he's still in
office and I haven't heard a word from
one of the I believers he got Keith
Ellis and he got a promotion
Bill Clinton served two terms as
president what about the issue of Russia
collusion what two and a half years of
conspiracy theories lies and a hoax
Hillary's bought and paid for dirty
Russian dossier put together by a
foreign spy with funneled money filled
with Russian lies as John Solomon will
join us in a minute points out even the
FBI knew 90 plus percent of it was a lie
and now we also know that it was
unverifiable because of course
Christopher steel never stood behind his
own dossier I don't have any idea if
it's true he said under oath and don't
forget the media just spent months
hyping phantom claims of instruction
against Trump did any of them ever talk
about Hillary subpoenaed emails that she
deleted and then the bleach bit to the
hard drive and acid washed the 33,000
emails and then of course beating up the
device's with hammers removing SIM cards
and by the way other evidence all of
that happening so when you turn on
conspiracy theory democratic state TV
either
MSDN see or fake news CNN and you hear
the echo chamber in their full typical
daily freakout mode just know that it's
more selective moral outrage they don't
really care about these issues they only
care about them if they can use them to
bludgeon a Republican a conservative or
Trump or anybody that likes trunk and
nobody calls their Bluff better than
President Trump